baby we go live on
Wednesdays that's how we do it baby we
go live like
this ladies and
gentlemen welcome
back to your favorite
[Music]
podcast
w
real what's up y'all big episode
today you know personal stuff got my tax
is done some crook situations going on
here um what else uh paper straws turns
out they're bad for you um dogs in
restaurants do we like it plus Marvel's
Echo Bill Mars back with real time and
my favorite couple on 90day
fiance so we back again and you know how
we
do
[Music]
yeah all right man we're back we're back
on with Griffin let me put this on do
not disturb so nobody calls me anyways
welcome back to Griffin with Griffin I'm
your host Eric
Griffin and welcome you
know you don't know what this is it's uh
you know comedy podcast more like a
personal stream of
Consciousness uh it's me sometimes I'm
funny sometimes I'm introspective but
I'm always 100% me for the new people
thanks for being here for the old people
you know how we do so make sure if
you're like you know hey I want to find
out when this podcast is coming on you
know that's why you got to hit that
subscribe button hit the Subscribe
button so you can get the notifications
and you know when I'm going live which
is Wednesday uh twitch I'm on Twitch all
the time guys a game Eric Griffin gaming
on Twitch so follow me there and you
want to follow me there because if you
follow me there you'll get updated on um
when I'm doing my new content so I have
bonus content now every Monday and you
could be a patreon subscriber to get
that come to
patreon to get uh that oh and also it'll
be like I I guess I should also put like
the commercial fee commercial free
versions of the show on there too when I
because I got some more ads coming so I
yeah I forgot about that so I should do
that too so come there check me out if
you want to be a supporter of the show
YouTube member excuse me patreon if you
follow me on Twitch because I I on
Mondays I go live on Twitch for
subscribe rers only and you can get like
a free preview for like 5 minutes and
then you have to like um you know see
how that's going so make sure you check
me out there um you know and I
appreciate that that's been going strong
I've been consistent with it I've been
saying I've been doing it for years and
I'm doing it patreon content is live
every Monday come check that out all
right so thanks for being here on riffin
with Griffin appreciate you guys lot to
talk about today I see somebody in the
chat and thank you for also the people
that
listen platforms that where you guys uh
you know listen to the podcast I
appreciate that too thanks for doing
that on Apple Apple pod Spotify all
those places all those truck drivers all
those people that have those jobs where
they have to like listen to something to
keep them occupied I'm glad I'm part of
your
life um personal note you know just I
want to send out I just want to send out
some love and some support to my boy
Brendan sha you know his little girl his
newborn is is ill getting emergency
surgery this week so that's a really
tough thing as a as a future parent I'm
you know we're I'm in our we're are
almost we're 39 weeks right now you know
it just makes me think about like oh man
what you know what would I do what would
I be feeling it would be devastating
just to be dealing with this so I want
you to send out some love and support
for Brendan you know it's like this guy
gets so much hate it's just crazy the
the amount of hate that this guy gets
for for it seemingly for like no reason
just like because people like to like
there there's a there's a YouTube page
where the guy made some video about
Brendan and got a million views right
and then he repurposed the video did it
again and got another million views it's
like so you just trying to make money
off the hating to do it's like there's a
business in hating this guy and I just I
don't get
it um so anyways I just want you to like
uh send just
pause your hate and send some good
thoughts out in the universe for the guy
because no one no matter who it is
deserves to be dealing with a sick child
okay so thank you for that um anyways
what else is uh going on
[Music]
um yeah man
I I don't know you know listen I I don't
know if any of you guys are Incorporated
you know so I have es Corp you know you
got you know you get Incorporated in
into business it's like you know it's
it's supposedly good for taxes whatever
it is like that let tell you right now
it's a hassle okay and I've had three
different tax guys all right three
different tax people my first tax guy
you know recommended by a friend of mine
this guy did not do my taxes right okay
and I know this because when I went to
to someone else the guy the person was
looking over the stuff like oh my God
God this guy didn't do your things right
and I'm like what and then I was getting
constant notices from the IRS like for 4
years okay maybe even longer than that
I'm getting notices from the IRS this
wasn't done right this wasn't done right
you owe this you owe that you didn't
report this right you didn't report this
right so the guy was incompetent just
incompetent okay hassle all right and
when you're Incorporated oh my God you
have to do all this nonsense anyways
anyways then I go to a new guy
recommended by someone else I go to this
guy and this guy's a used car salesman
man used car salesman bro this guy you
know oh we got to do this and you know
it's like tax people try to convince you
that they're going to help you
basically lie to the government right if
you know what I mean like they're going
to like that's the that's the Crux of it
they're going to help you like pay as
little taxes as possible that's what
these tax people do
but how they get it back is they
overcharge you so they're like well
you're not going to give the money to
the government you're going to give the
money to us so I'm with this guy this
new this new firm and they're too big
like it's like you go to one of these
firms when you're like an esor
incorporated of just you I don't have a
small business I don't own a damn dry
cleaners or something like that or a dut
shop and you know I have employees and I
need somebody to go through these
tactics it's just
me this [__] charge me like I'm
a Fortune 500 company you know what I
mean so that and then in the end it just
turned out the dude was just Shady so
that company shady and so I had you know
I had to leave them and when I'm calling
them out they actually left me they were
like yeah we're not going to work with
you anymore because I'm calling them out
on their nonsense so then I get
recommended again to these new people I
like them the orig the original guy that
I met with he was a nice guy he's come
to my shows he was a cool dude but my
fees we're getting to the point where I
was like what and just to give you an
example what I'm saying is just for like
two quarters of taxes I was being
charged almost
$6,000 that's just to let you know what
I'm talking
about that's a lot of freaking money
anyways so now I need to talk to this
guy he's come to my shows we've gone to
dinner we have like a little personal
relationship and and I'm thinking all
right he's going to he's G to help me
out I know he is
he
dies and rip to him and condolences to
his family he
dies now this tax
company they are what they're trying to
charge me and how they're treating me
the dude is turning in his grave I'm
sure so my the dude didn't recommended
the last two tax places he said hey man
I'm leaving those that place cuz it was
the guy that died that's the reason why
I went there and do you need a
recommendation from my my guy I said to
my dude no thank you cuz you are 0 for
two on tax people 0 for two
okay exactly Alfred Wayne in the chat
it's like and then you have to deal with
the California tax codes and the
overcharging I mean it's like it's
crazy but let me just tell you something
right now you can't be cheap on your
taxes right like like how you get it
done but you have to go with people that
you trust but I have a conversation with
the guy you know from the place where
the guy that died his like person that
was working with him and this guy on the
phone is basically admitting to me like
yeah you know yeah we're
overcharging he goes you know this is
just how it is the industry is you know
it's about the up UPS making their money
and hitting their quotas and he's
basically admitting to me that his firm
is full of [__] okay that's where I'm at
right now with it I'm just so Furious
and so now I need like to go to the new
guy and they're like talking about all
these extra fees I have to pay they're
like oh well you know you need to pay
because we did fourth quarter and you
know he's all like you know Don't Kill
the Messenger man it's from the up and
the UPS you know what I mean I'm just
like oh man I just want
to just be careful you know what I mean
I'm just telling you guys be careful cuz
you know they're all Crooks
man they're all Crooks just piss me off
man anyways you know went to the doctor
with h Rachel and you know we're doing
good you know I think today or tomorrow
we're actually at 39 weeks so then it's
any day now real I realized you know I
thought it was like the 27th but then it
was like we talked to the doctor and you
know it's like they they determin like
so I apparently the original first time
we went in original ultrasound they gave
us an estimation
that it was supposed to be February
1st and then later we go again 10 weeks
12 then it changed to 27th but now that
when we're in there they got the people
like actually it's looking more like the
the
first
so I need this baby to show up already
you know what I mean just the anxiety of
all that it's like it's a lot but
everything's going well so thanks to
everybody that you know if you thoughts
oh and by the way I also want to thank
everybody that's like sent something a
lot of my gaming people from Mar Griffin
gaming we've been a family since the
pandemic you know they've been following
me and they've been subscribing and you
know you know I talk to them almost
every day online you know I know some of
them they show they come to the shows
like if you're a subscriber on Twitch
and I'm coming to your town you come to
the show you hit me up I'll get you in
if you're a subscriber you know what I
mean so I I've met a lot of them it's
they're cool people man and so I
appreciate that you know it's like there
are a lot of trolls online there are
there's just a lot of trolls for no
reason reason like you know people like
attention people like putting like
negative comments to like you know get a
rise out of you and stuff like that they
you know there's a lot of those people
and the good people you guys you know I
have to remember that there's a lot of
good people because I have a lot of
subscribers you know what I mean so
those subscribers are the good people
you know they just don't always comment
like I I realize that this the the
internet world is you just want to enjoy
the content you just you don't want to
engage in stuff like you might want to
put like a fun com comment like hey
doing whatever but then you know these
trolls are going to attack so you're
just kind of like eh I'll support from
afar but the ones that you know
unfortunately sadly sad part about it is
the ones that we see as the as the
content creator you you know it's just a
bunch do you see the negativity you're
like ah damn just like what's up with
this but you know there's just those how
people
are um so anyways that's just that just
that just is what it is you know what I
mean so I don't know
you know what I mean and then people
think they like I see this thing about
like Bobby said something on bad friends
you know that's just how he is you know
we talk smack about each other when we
see each other but like you know he does
something like that on his podcast and
then the trolls take that and they think
like oh man and then they then they go
on the attack and it's just like you
know but it's the downside of like being
a content creator on the internet but it
is what it is so whatevers
um yeah man let's see what else um let's
go into that's it for for that right now
so let's let's get into comments and
then uh we'll get into the
episode and like I say I appreciate you
guys being here as always okay um let's
see
here uh Vaz
music for my money I'm dying up here
with one of the best shows ever it would
be great if they had another season that
explain where the comics ended up if it
was a single 2hour movie oh who you
telling
right I know I just feel like I'm dying
up here it just needed one more season I
think to really but listen you need two
things for a premium cable show to
succeed to keep going for them to invest
the money in it you have to have
critical Acclaim and you have to have
viewership you have to have one of the
two or one has to be really good and the
other one you know you have to have one
of those we didn't with a critical claim
was like 5050 and we didn't get a a
large viewership because it's showtime
you know you have to be subscribed to
Showtime you know I think if if the show
was on Netflix or something else I think
it would have been I think it would have
lasted it would have really been like oh
this is a great show but it is what it
is but thank you for
that um David Appleton one day ago do
you wonder why Stephen Hawking is on the
list could it be invalidated the list in
people's mind this can't be a list of
kitty Fiddlers because this one can't
move and it's on a wheelchair not my
opinion just a thought yeah I understand
what you mean it's like you know when it
comes to the Epstein list it's all guilt
by association at this point you know
what I mean that's how we look at it
it's like everybody's Guilty By
Association sadly you know I do feel
like there's a lot of people that was on
like this guy was like if you look at
Epstein's history he was a finance year
and he you know he was a smooth talking
dude who knew how to get into circles
and he had a lot of Rich powerful people
around and so yeah there was probably
some of those people that he confided in
like yo are you into this cuz I'm into
this and they were like yeah man and
come to my Island and then I think there
were other people who were just kind of
like enamored by you know you know like
if it think of it this way let's say you
started a company and you're like you
know and then some financier guy's like
hey man how you doing well you know you
need to come into my circles and they
and the guy goes yeah you know um come
to this party you you could you know
former president's going to be there
Bill Gates is going to going to be there
uh you know celebrities are going to be
there and uh we're going to talk
business and finance and stuff and then
you go and you're like damn why would
you say no prince Andrew is going to be
there you know what I'm saying like you
you might be like okay so I kind of feel
like I don't think everybody should have
a sweeping brush of like everybody's a
pervert and I do think it's like there
has to be like you don't just put out a
flyer hey you know you and the kids come
to my Island I think that there was like
a vetting process for Epstein and he
probably this was it he probably invited
people places and stuff and then maybe
some people saw some things that made
them uncomfortable and then shame on
them for not saying anything I guess too
right or just people were just like n
you know all right and he he got a sense
like he had to have a sense like who he
could talk to and who he can't there had
to be he had to get a sense like well if
I say this to this person this person is
going to make a big stink about it you
know what I'm saying so all I'm saying
is I don't think there should be a broad
brush that everybody was guilty you know
Steph you're Stephen Hawking you're in a
a wheelchair you're widely regarded as
the smartest human being ever Stephen
Hawking's got to be regarded as top five
Mount Rushmore of smartest people ever
so of course he's going to be in the
circles of like Rich powerful people you
know what I'm saying so who knows you
know I know what you mean though it's
like was he just propped in there but
you know conspiracies and all it's like
who knows but all I'm saying is like we
should have some Grace for some of the
people that's on this list that it keeps
coming
out all right um
um let's see all
right oh man I don't even know I saw
some of
these
uh you know this is the kind of thing
I'm talking about I don't normally like
reading these kind of comments but it's
like this is the kind of
comment that a person thinks it's either
one oh no this is a good comment or two
oh I have to be a backhanded
condescending troll the guy goes not my
favorite comedian or podcast but has the
coldest intro of all time much love
man you know what I'm saying it's like
you got on the outfit and this dude
would be like you know what not my
favorite colors uh not my favorite style
but man that hat you got on you know
what I mean it's like I don't know but
shout out to JC Wonderland I guess thank
you you know what I mean
uh all right let's see here uh
conspiracy Center
7427 I mean this guy God bless your mom
we will pray for her thank you very much
everyone when the people that send me
messages about my mom I really
appreciate that you
know um let's
see let's see let's see let's see let's
see
um let's see where we're at here just
one guy I don't know this guy there's
there there's like a lot of
[__]
um oh no no you know what it is let me
give me get the ones I forgot that I
have some ones that I've responded to
okay so this is the last one I'll talk
about most down two days ago I agree
with you Eric that it's very nuanced and
people aren't trained in media literacy
listen to all sides to find the truth I
think the bottom line with the George
Floyd story is that no matter if
someone's Under the Influence or has a
record it doesn't justify the
disappropriate use of force and it
doesn't deserve the
un living by need what what I I don't
understand this word but I'm just being
stupid right now but anyway about the
knee to the throat they determined the
level threat and he wasn't packing heat
all right so last week I did bring up
George Floyd and I brought up this um
what do you call it this documentary
that came out last week I talked about
it the fall of Minnesota you know and
I've got a lot of comments and people
have hit me up about it there was one
guy on Instagram that was just like you
know it's one of these things where like
like this kind of stuff happens and you
know people get like immediately like
man I can't believe you uh uh you you
you know you think that he deserved to
die I was like I didn't I never said
that you know I think a lot of times
people I I think a lot of times people
watch I think people watch the show for
a second they see one thing and then
they they immediately go I gotta comment
on this without
actually
uh without actually like listening to
the whole thing or listening to all my
thoughts you know this is a stream of
conscious I'm just talking about things
and you know so you have to listen to
the whole thing but I do want to go back
to I do want to go back to that
um yeah see one thing I didn't mention
last week or I don't even remember if I
did mention last week wait what's going
on here is this still working I'm I'm
seeing like my my thing is paused for a
second here let me refresh there's
always something with this man always
something I hope this is still working
are you guys still getting it yeah you
are all right so anyway sorry so one
thing I do want to mention that uh that
from from last week is that I didn't
mention this and maybe I did I don't
remember but I have had to call the
police on someone who was on drugs drunk
and acting crazy just I've I've had to
do that
and the procedure to was was different
you know they came and I'll never forget
this they had
to they had to chase him down like in
the room the the the the fire EMT people
grabbed him put him down sedated him
they gave him a shot and immediately
started acting different like
immediately he was calm and they they
sat him down in the chair they strapped
him in and they took him
away so for me when I look at like that
the the the the foot footage of George
Floyd I see that immediately the cops
that first came on the scene they knew
something was up they knew something was
up with this guy because one they asked
him are you on something of course he
said no like yeah he's GNA say no what
what guy's going to be like yeah I'm
taking illegal substances right you're
not going to tell that to the cops so of
course he said no but they knew they
assessed it they don't ask that to
everyone they don't pull everyone over
and it's not like procedure to ask
someone on a routine stop or even if
like whatever hey are you on something
no they would assess that I think the
initial cops assessed it I think that
they they tried to arrest him he was
resisting arrest for a long time and the
problem came is when these new cops came
onto the scene when the new cops came
onto the scene it seemed to me that they
didn't have enough conversation like yo
we already cuz the guy said he called it
the one said hey call the EMT the the
cop you hear him say it on the tape from
the the body cam footage call the you
know so I don't think there was any like
the the cops that were on the scene
should have said to the cops that came
yeah this is the situation man we think
something's this guy's on something and
you know he did something and then like
it seems to me like the the new cops
that came they just kind of took over
and the guy was like all right and they
did this by the book you put your KNE
that's how you sub uh subdue uh a person
right with that technique that's in the
Minnesota cops handbook but what I'm
saying is this did none of that wasn't
handled right none of that was handled
right this documentary does not absolve
these cops of what happened to him in
fact in my opinion it makes it worse
because they have now proved that he was
on drugs that he was not acting of his
right mind so therefore the procedure to
how you handle him should have been
handled completely
differently anyways but that's uh what I
have to say about that so but thanks for
all the comments guys thanks for
listening thanks for getting involved
and I love when people comment cuz I
will you know if it's a good comment I
will
respond um yeah so something I wanted to
talk about is you know yeah you guys
been thinking about like you know how
the world changes man the world freaking
changes I'm at have you noticed that you
just at a restaurant a
supermarket a place where there's food
like the the place where there's food
that that's the main thing I'm saying
and it's just dogs just people just
walking around with dogs just like in
the aisles at the supermarket dogs
sniffing stuff and he's just kind of
like when did this become a thing where
we just don't
care there's food here there's like you
know what I mean you know and it's like
they just walking around with the dogs
and then like you know the dogs are
peeing or something or I just like we
have literally just there was a time and
this is what I'm saying about like as
you get older and and you know when you
get older you will have more memories
when you get older you will see the
differences in errors you know it's like
guess you look at like TV it's like I'm
51 so I can remember watching even
reruns of I Love Lucy and Lucy and Rick
or sleeping in different beds because
that came from a time when it wasn't
okay to show that on TV right now people
have a sex on TV you know what I'm
saying so if you're an older person you
just you know your your mind so you have
to adapt that's what makes old people
become out of touch when they don't
adapt their thinking or or accept or at
least have a critical thought about it
but like dog this is one of them things
let me tell you something I can remember
a time one when you left the restaurant
they called it a doggy
bag it was you took your food home
because you was G to give it to your dog
they stopped that 30 years ago saying
that now it's just you want to take home
bag you want a box take this food home
to eat later right don't you know you
know there was no
thought of a dog being in a restaurant
like when I was a kid that would be
crazy if you went some place and you saw
a dog you want to talk about like the
kons would have been out in force of all
colors and races been like there's a dog
there's a dog in the supermarket like it
would be like that is would be like
thought of as the most disgusting thing
you've ever thought of in your life to
see an an where there's food but in
California man I don't care where you
are you at Air1 you at the most
expensive place the poorest Place do
people got like fullon 95 PB German
Shepherds walking around the produce
section of a supermarket with a big ass
dog it's already like dogs on airplanes
and all that kind of stuff where you go
you you see this and you're like what
cuz my thing is like just the assumption
that everybody like what if you're
you're like to me you should have like
on airlines it should say I'm allergic
to dogs I'm allergic to dogs I don't
care about your like you have uh you
know a rescue dog not s a rescue dog
what is it like a comfort a support
animal you have a support animal I don't
care if I'm allergic to dogs I don't
want to sit next to you so that should
be a thing like that should be a thing
you're asking about it's like but we
change our lives for for the minority so
so there's one person that has a thing
and all of a sudden now all everything
has to change for this one person for
this small group of people I mean it's
crazy man I'm just asking so my my
question to the chat my question to the
podcast my question to the viewers is
like do you ever think about it anymore
or is it just like cuz one day I was
just in the market and there was like
three dogs in there and I didn't think
anything of it till I was walking out I
just you know you see a dog you're like
a cute dog you know what I mean you're
just like okay you know one lady had a
dog in the cart you know what I'm saying
dog was in the cart pushing the cart and
I thought oh that's cute and I thought
about it like when did this become cute
when did this become acceptable and do
you ever think about it you know what I
mean do you ever think about it
so
just I just don't get it you know I
don't get it and this leads me to my
next conversation guys my next
conversation is about turns out and
there's like a you could just Google it
there's a bunch of stories about it
bunch of stories about it so let me I
hope my uh I hope my thing works today I
think I have it set up right today let's
see and
yes paper straws are more likely to
contain harmful forever chemicals than
plastic straws new research
finds there is a number of stories right
now on the internet on Instagram on t
Tik Tok about how doctors are now
showing paper straws are not good for
you because of the glue whatever they're
using to keep them together you know but
you know what it's crazy it's like so
they didn't look into this so this is
the thing I'm saying about like I always
feel like the there's like if you
believe in the
Illuminati if you believe that there's
like a cabal of rich people that run the
world and make choices about things okay
I can see people believe in that cuz
money is you know money is power you
know and uh you have money you have
power right okay but right now in
society I feel like another Illuminati
is this loud minority of people on the
internet on both sides but the ones that
we seem to be changing our lives for is
this Progressive liberal Lefty
philosophies and we just change it like
this with no thought no research we just
do it to appease these people so it
became a whole thing about Plastics
straws and you know all and then the
turtles and the fish and whoever we're
killing in the ocean and where the
things are ending
up okay and then we were like okay so
then they they they rushed to me they
rushed they were like okay um all right
let's make paper straws and all these
companies oh let's make these
straws there's no oversight on the
straws so now they're coming out like
yeah you know these straws have glue and
it's breaking down and you're drinking
it into your system you ever get a paper
straw and the [__] is all soggy and
stuff well what's happening to that
stuff right what's happening of course
like of course if you put paper in water
and just let it sit there what happens
to the paper of course it's going to
like you know and if you're and if
you're putting the straw together with
glue and chemicals where did those
chemicals go but no one cared we just
needed to appease the Lefty Illuminati
we needed to make them they were like
straws are bad and we need to change and
they were like yes and then all the
companies were like okay I guess um to
make money we have to make straws so do
you think the PE let me ask you this
question question for the chat question
for people listening right
now do you think that the Mega
corporations like say like Starbucks for
instance or let's let's go a better
McDonald's so do you think McDonald's
who is using plastic
straws that they you know because it's
cheap and affordable and whatever uh you
think that they are now going to make
sure that the paper straws they get are
better for you than the plastic straws
of course not they don't care they just
going with like whatever people say
they're like yeah you know these people
are loud on the internet and they're
like we need oh I can't believe this is
happening then they're like okay they
okay uh make paper straws and then the
paper straws that come there's no
oversight there's no paper straw
committee you you know what I mean they
just did it and then these idiots are
walking around in West Hollywood and and
and and and and Silver Lake and all the
you know all the
freaking Fufu places with your paper
straws
like yeah I I care about the
environment and their dog also inside
the coffee shop by the way these are the
same [__] they got the dog in
the coffee shop with their paper straw
and they want to look at you with an
attitude like look how good of a person
I am I am such a good person with my
paper straw no turns out your paper
straw is killing you
[__]
it's it's just it baffles the mind you
know
so because we never really deal with the
issues you know so it's it's just kind
of like you know they you know they you
know how they used to give sodas in
those uh those plastic things you know
you take the soda out it would be like
this plastic ring of like six and they
would just throw that in the ocean and
then it would kill Turtles and stuff and
so now we made it about that see it
ain't about the plastic [__] killing the
turtles no it's about why are we
throwing that stuff in the ocean that is
the issue like yes could there be a
better thing to do with plastic maybe we
need some reusable renewable renewable
stuff maybe there has to be some way
that when you take Plastics you put it
in some kind of fusion reactor and it
turns it into something else whatever
that should be the thing we should be
discussing because you know what we not
we're not hearing about I can't wait
till you hear about all the masks we've
been wearing for four years during the
pandemic are where are they at where are
all the masks at did are they were they
all biodegradable are they like just is
there like a a mask Island out in the o
oan someplace like when are they going
to talk about that are those mask ropes
choking out fish when are when are they
going to talk about that right it's like
we never deal with the real
issues the
issue is beyond just Plastics the issue
should be why is trash ending up in the
ocean let's stop there but no everybody
want like a quick fix the Quick Fix is
like okay Plastics bad all right and
then somebody was like well just send
them paper straws you know and then it
had to be somebody was like nobody
thought like well how do they putting
these straws together like how are they
making them is there any chemicals
anything like that and chemicals coming
off paper so easy you know it's like
that you know when you lick an envelope
when's the last time you licked an
envelope for you young people an
envelope is something that you would put
letters and things in and you would seal
it and mail it when your mail comes
that's an
envelope like you know what I mean like
yeah you ever think like well what's
that made of no we would just
like we would just [__] go down on
the envelope like it was a you know $15
hooker that you met at an alley in
Downtown
LA you you know what I'm saying like
it's it's
crazy it's just crazy to think that like
whatever those chemicals are do we we
just assume that the companies would
what they wouldn't put poison on the on
the envelopes right it apparently you
know what they would they actually would
there's somebody deciding hey you know
it costs more if we make sure these
chemicals don't kill people and somebody
was like well how much more and the guy
was like then he was like ah just use
the other one I mean that's
basically that's
basically what this kind of stuff is so
anyway my point is not to go on a long
tangent like I just did is I am not
shocked that this is the situation and
as usual with no thought with just like
the idea of like wanting everybody to
think they're a good person cuz that's
what this really is about hey I'm a good
person I care about the environment I
care about people no thought process at
all they just assumed oh well the straws
are good they have to be good and we
changed our world for these people and
now look what's happening you know what
this is just like too this is just like
all the this is all of the body
positivity fat people who are
dead that's going to go away too that's
backfiring on people too you know all
the people who were like you know stop
fat shaming you know body fat positivity
all this stuff there's so many videos
out now about all of the people who are
dead from health related issues from
being [__]
fat and where are all those Progressive
liberal I care about the world people
now are you going to these fat people's
funerals
being like you
know she was beautiful and you it's like
who you speaking for now see they were
just doing that for themselves all those
type of people they don't really care
about these fat [__] they don't care
about them they just want everybody to
think they're a good person so they pick
a concept they pick a a ideology and
they go yeah that sounds right it sounds
right uh let's normalize being fat look
at me everybody I'm a good person and
then those people who were perpetuating
that they're
dead they're they're dying all the time
now when you look on the internet you
see a lot of like workout stuff now hey
get work out in 24 hour 24 days get in
shape you know OIC like everybody's into
like you know losing weight now
everybody's into all this stuff I can't
wait for that those drugs I can't wait
in 10 years all the lawsuits and people
that their bodies are going to like
something's going to happen to them
because of all that stuff but it's
like I'm annoyed I'm just annoyed man
and this is an example of it paper
straws body positivity dogs and freaking
supermarkets all of it's crazy okay can
we take a beat you know can we not pay
can can we not make can we is there
another alternative besides pay straws
can we do something else you know just
have the you know don't even use a straw
how about that just get rid of straws
let's just stop using straws okay just
have the little sippy cup things for
everybody there we go which is being
thrown away and put into the ocean too
by the way you know what I mean it's
like can we deal with the real
issues stop normalizing fat it's not
okay okay I'm saying that as a fat
person I work out I'm working out all
the time now you know how hard it is and
I'm still like I still can't I let me
tell you something I feel better I have
more energy I feel like I can run now I
get on a treadmill when I first got on a
treadmill and I was walking I was like
okay you know what I'm doing now I do
interval training so now when I when I
start my workout I I I walk for 15
minutes when I get to the 9 Minute Mark
I run for a minute like 5 miles an hour
I run and I had to work up to 5 miles an
hour so now I can run for a minute
straight Then I then I slow it down from
5 back down to 3 and I walk for a minute
and then I run again for a minute and I
do that four times and I feel myself you
know I feel like oh man look at me I got
and it's still hard okay it's hard right
I still don't see the like the actual
results that you know we all want but I
feel better what I'm saying is let's
stop normalizing fat [__]
walking around looking like elephants
and [__] we need to stop that we need to
stop acting like that [__] is okay it's
not I'm sick of it cuz they're dying and
then where are all the good people
there's no good people where are they
we're all the good people being like Oh
my condolences my condolences to their
family who we were supporting body
positivity and telling this person that
being fat is okay where are they at now
they're gone they're just going to
disappear because they don't care
they're gonna move on to the next
freaking
thing [__] I'm on one today
huh on one today that should be the name
of the episode on one I might change the
name of the episode okay
anyways on a lighter note everyone Let's
uh I want to go into finish the episode
off with talking about my my different
reviews and stuff that uh of shows and
stuff that I want to talk about so first
show up is this show echo on Marvel my
question I have in the uh so so Disney
Disney Marvel you know they on this woke
Crusade and I think that they've damaged
Artistic integrity some of the times so
some of the times I see things and my
example of that would be Little Mermaid
okay so Little Mermaid you make Little
Mermaid black and I have no problem with
that okay first of all mermaids aren't
real okay so you can make Little Mermaid
black all right but then give her a
black family so let's make this family
black but no they can't do that she's
black and then you go under the sea and
meet her family her dad's Spanish why
why is her dad SP Spanish that's that
Disney [__] okay and and then not
even just that maybe the dad could be
Spanish right but like she got an Asian
sister an Indian sister two white girls
it's like what are we talking about
anyway that's an example where it's like
that's woke gone wrong the the the the
um the eternals the eternals another
ridiculous story okay another ridiculous
casting choices you know so you got so
so so in the eternals this like God
creature that that created the
eternals why would he make the eternals
this way you know oh a middle-aged
Mexican woman with a Mexican accent from
7 thou she's 7,000 years old she got a
Mexican accent why why a fat gay guy
that wears glasses
why why make this Choice it don't make
sense for the Artistic integrity of the
story that so so there are examples of
when you look at Disney and you're
like what
what what are you talking
about oh my god did Le okay I got to
take a pause for a second because I
didn't know Leslie told this story on
Bobby's podcast so I will tell the
story okay all right so Leslie Jones
longtime friend of mine all right she
was Leslie wasn't always doing as well
as she's doing now and she used to
borrow money all the time from people
she borrowed money from me
and I gave her the money but here's the
thing she was asking for money from
numerous of my friends we're all texting
each other we're texting each other
about it like oh man guess what did
Leslie hit you up about getting so I
just happened to be in a text thread
with other friends talking about this
what I accidentally did was I sent her
the text message cuz I was texting with
her so I I sent her the text message
like
this uh yeah Leslie borrowing money
again y'all and it was to
her and I was
like she didn't talk to me for like 10
years I mean what are you supposed to do
right it's just one you know what I own
it I own it I made a mistake it it would
be like if you a player you know how you
dudes are you a player and you like you
send one girl a message like yo what's
up boo boo and then like like you say
something to you texted three girls at
once and then one of the girls You' be
like oh yeah last night was fun and
other girl's like what last night I
didn't see you last night uh
oh so that's what happened my you know
like I publicly apologize to Leslie I
didn't know you know what I mean that
that even though that that probably that
probably at the time made her feel
horrible but to her
credit now she's Rich she done she done
done it you know SNL movies TV shows
she's a household name so about a few
months
back she gave she wrote me a check for
the money and a bottle of something I
don't drink so I forgot what it was asab
be like hey thanks I remember what you
did back in the day and we all good now
when I see her we all good so but I
haven't talked to her about this but I'm
when the next time I see her I am going
to have to bring this
up so anyway
anyways
H uh anyways so that's what it is man so
appreciate um you know so anyways Echo
so now getting back to Disney this show
Echo I like it it's like if you guys saw
Hawkeye she was this deaf character
she's Indian she got one leg it feels
like uh-oh that sounds kind of wokey a
Indian deaf girl with one leg you you go
what but it's actually a character from
the Marvel Universe and I actually
personally like any kind of Native
American Indian stuff because you know
what sometime it's like it's like a rich
culture and it's always about magic and
wolves or or lions or some kind of like
you know uh Native American Customs that
led to like it's great for
Supernatural stuff and so a lot of times
when they use that it's great and
there's a lot of great actors out there
too that don't get enough shine that
these people in this show are doing a
great job
I actually really like Ekko it's only a
six-part miniseries and of course the
guy that plays Kingpin uh what's his
name
um what is his name Vincent denafo you
know he's great actor he plays Kingpin
so that Universe of like Daredevil
Kingpin Spider-Man all that kind of
stuff in Marvel there's a lot of great
characters that are in the Daredevil
universe and Echoes one of them so um I
I enjoy it I know but listen when you
know how woke Disney is and you hear
deaf one-legged Native American woman
you're like here we
go you know what I mean you be like here
we go Disney you're at it again Disney
is at it again but no just so you know
this one's actually I do like it it's a
good one okay so don't don't get all
whatever about that all right so echo's
good I highly recommend it man I'm
running out of time for all the stuff
you guys got me I'm on one
today so guys I love this show 90day
fiance and I'm not sure which one this
is but this couple right here is my
favorite couple this girl Nicole
Sanders uh ex erotic dancer Star Porn
and she's with this guy Justin some from
malova okay this is the couple so here's
the thing they've been together on and
off for like years okay she's like 47
now he's in his 30s but they were
together say 10 years ago and they were
together
turns out she's trans and when he and
did he didn't know and then when he
found out it really messed with him
which I mean I don't know I don't know
how you guys feel about that I don't
think it's a terrible thing somebody
like they're taking back because they
didn't know this information especially
if they're talking about they want to be
in a long-term relationship like what do
you think of that like let's say if
you're on Tinder and you're just hooking
up and you're slid you're you know
you're you're going right you're trying
to hook up whatever and you meet a trans
person that don't know and they don't
tell you but you on some hookup [__]
what I don't know if it matters I don't
think it should matter right because
that's all your intention is but if your
intention is like you're looking for a
long-term relationship because you want
to start a family and that person
doesn't tell you that they can't have
kids how about this forget that they're
trans say it's just a just you know a
woman who's not trans and then they
don't tell you that they can't have kids
and you you're you're holding that I
want to have kids I want to have a
family then you get all close and fall
in love and then they tell you oh yeah I
can't have kids would that be messed up
I think it's the same thing I think it's
the same thing okay so at what point is
is a person obligated to say something I
don't know but anyways they messed up
then they got back you know he but then
now they're getting back together and
he's trying to come to grips with it
because he loves her right brings her to
malova to meet his parents and then
you're you're talking about a place that
like trans is not okay right and he's
trying to like you know but the dude the
dude is ill man he talks so matter
factly he might even be Autistic or
something in terms of like you know or
it's just his accent or something cuz
he's just so matter a fact about stuff
you know she's like well you know she
started the K1 Visa process and all that
then finally gets there and she's like
well have you been with other women
without even a pause he was like yeah
you know I have a couple of you
know and then the girl's like what you
know and he's just like what that was
the past like why why can't we just move
forward he does that kind of stuff all
the time like he won't have sex with her
because he has a problem with it he
can't get past the idea that this used
to be a man type of thing right and then
so he's he'll be like well why don't we
let's have threesome you know he in his
mind he's trying to work it out you know
what I
mean he trying to like and this is his
way of working it out well let's just
bring other women in you I just have
with them you know I love you you'll be
there
too and then she's like okay if you want
to do that then let's have two men and
he's like oh whoa whoa whoa I don't like
the idea of another man being inside you
he's like so matter of fact it's like
the dude is ill but it's like it's just
funny to watch the this my favorite
couple y'all got to check them out they
are so crazy this
couple um I mean man I'm going to go
into like I don't know we're getting
into like there's so much I don't want
to I don't want to leave anything out
um so the last one was like about Bill
Maher the new show real talk I like real
talk with Bill Maher um I think that
over the years you know he has been a
big strong supporter of democracy and
Democrats and the left but but you know
rightly so in the last like few years he
has seen the Democratic party become
crazy being pushed by the far-left
extremist of things and he doesn't like
it and he's speaking about it and what
happens when you do that here's what
happens in society that I don't like if
you are considered a Democrat if you are
a Democrat if you're a liberal you want
you know and then like you see some
weirdness going on in your party or some
some things that you don't like and you
speak on it all of a sudden now you're a
right-wing C it's crazy how the things
have flipped it's turned out it turns
out it seems as if the left is the ones
that are anti-free speech anti-
discussion you know what I mean it's
like no you should be able to talk about
things you should be able to see and I
think Bill Mah does a great job of that
but I see online all the hate that he
gets he just gets so much hate from like
like like prominent celebrity type
people are like oh that guy's a bigot
listen you don't have to agree with the
things that everything that he says but
he inspires a conversation he'll have
different types of people on his show
from both sides and he'll Grill people
about stuff but when he grills people on
the left like what what so if you're on
the the left if you're Democrat you're
supposed to just sit by and act like all
this stuff that's happening is okay no
no we live in a country that's supposed
to be have some discourse has we we're
living in a place where you know you
that's what free speech is all about
being able to like talk about things
even things that you don't like and I
think that Bill Maher does a great job
of that and like I say you don't have to
agree with him but I think that his show
is important it's one of the few places
on TV you can go and hear other opinions
other than your own it is not a echo
chamber and I just find it I just really
think that this is a big issue where
it's just a left Echo chamber and a
right one too by the way too I'm not let
me not bad like both sides the extremes
of both sides just you're just like whoa
this is how you think this is how you
think but it seems the thing the
difference is though we're not changing
our world we're not letting dogs we we
don't let you know dogs into restaurants
and and straws and and all this kind of
stuff that's going on that seems to be
like we we change our world for the left
and then for the right we just go ah
they're uneducated they're stupid or
whatever we we kind of like downgrade
the other side and I think that there
there's there's enough blame to go
around on both sides so but anyways
shout out to Bill Mah I do think you
should check out his show agree with him
or not just check out his show just so
you can like make yourself think about
different things man make yourself think
about you know what's going on in our
world and is this okay you know what I
mean I just that's what I think man so I
think it's an important show and I'm
glad he's on the air and I think you
guys should definitely check it
out all right man you know I wanted to
get into this uh you
know um real world
advice from a grown ass man where's my
little oh man my thing went away I don't
know what happened to it but I had like
a whole thing for it but it it disapp I
I guess it messed up I have to fix that
again but anyways guys you know I guess
I'm going to go a little long today but
um you know on Instagram I put up my my
thing for real world advice from a grown
ass man I haven't done it in a while and
so let me just go to some of the
questions and I'll just answer a few of
them somebody said tips on moving on
from a bad breakup tips from moving on
from a bad breakup listen you won't ever
forget it it's not going to just leave
your mind but I suggest you work on you
I've said this in the past and I'll say
it again work on you work out change
your eating habits sleep better work on
some Hobbies distract yourself but
improve yourself so when you move on to
the next thing you're going to be a
different person and it could be moving
on to the last thing because you've now
changed yourself and you're like
improving yourself and maybe maybe you
might look back and be like oh you know
what what was I doing with this person
or you may look back and be like you
know what maybe you were right and now I
I've made myself better for me and in
turn will make our relationship better
you know so that's what I think in terms
of that and by the way I always get to
stay as a disclaimer I am not a
therapist as you know I'm just giving
you real world advice from a grown ass
man if you do have issues and problems I
suggest you get therapy therapy is
important it's got a bad stigma but get
it now therapy is not going to solve
your problems what therapy's going to do
is help you recognize patterns and ways
to find some coping mechanisms to
improve what improve your situation
things to think about and so I suggest
therapy for anybody that has super real
issues but for some of the stuff I can
just you know go on somebody asked me
rate your early comedy years Open Mic
experience 1 to 10 o it was terrible I
hated my Open Mic experience it was
tough it was you know it's different you
get sometimes you had to pay you had to
drive all over the place you had to wait
it was a tough experience but it you
know it's part of the growing process
and I suggest every everybody does
it um let's
see all right super stressed about
trying to make my future and career
secure tips for creatives hey man
there's no real tips it's just that you
have to be consistent I mean I think
that's the main thing when you think
about people who blow up on the internet
you know people might look at The
Superficial things like say look at Matt
R they'll be like oh well Matt's cute uh
you know Matt's this no no this guy
works really hard and he has a team now
that he like puts out videos three or
four times a week it's a lot of work I
see him doing it the editing the the the
you know making sure it's different you
know so what that shows me is that it's
about hard work and consistency so if
you really want to make it in this thing
it's like don't just think about the
results you want I think you need to
think about the the journey towards it
and the work ethic you have to put into
it so check that
out found out my wife is pregnant what
things have have you done to get ready
for fatherhood man I don't even know
what it I I don't know you know it's
like not to worry as much uh be there
for a like I just try to be there for
Rachel you know it's like it's just a
tough thing man uh you know it's like I
realize how hard pregnancy is for women
so it's just like being there for her
being comfort and just like preparing
yourself I think that's what this nine
months is for I think it's it's it's
done this way by Design so we could
prepare ourselves and you know sort of
like get attached to the idea that we're
about to
worried about a another person's life
and be be responsible for it so for me
it's just been like
a you know you prepare the room and all
the I think all the little things that
the the the what do you call it the the
the doctor's visits everything helps
prepare you so just stay levelheaded and
make sure you work on you that's what
really inspired me to be like I got to
work out I'm going to a workout later
today I work out I try to work out three
times a week with my trainer and then I
I need to like pick up like doing my
cardio on the off days and make it a
habit that this is something that I do
that's how I'm preparing so good luck
man
um okay so somebody gave me some
somebody gave me some advice even after
a long day don't say no to playing with
your kids you can't be tired you could
be tired later huh already thinking
about that
man somebody said can you advise me on
finances no I
cannot wait let's see uh all right where
we at here H this was a funny one how do
I stop masturbating to porn in my porn
addiction I have I have I'm 27 it's
become a problem with my girlfriend yeah
I mean I think that this is a thing that
happens to a lot of young men you know I
mean I think that sometimes this this
has to do with other things and that's
why I say I encourage therapy in this
situation whatever your intimacy issues
are whatever you like you know not
interacting with real women enough real
women I think it's like you know just
spending too much time on the internet
spending too much time on Facebook
spending too much time on dating apps
whatever it is like that or not spending
enough time with your girlfriend
establishing some real intimacy with her
you know uh you know go out date you
know do do fun things together make make
being with her G find that same thing
that makes you excited that that you
know that that feeling that when you
look at porn you have to make make her
your focus and I totally understand why
she would be upset like yeah why are you
doing this all the time that's an
issue again no therapist so I you know I
think that you should look into that and
you know all right look into
it all right um if this will this will
be the last one and I might continue
this next week or on I'm actually on my
Monday my Monday
podcast my Monday live I'm going to deal
with this I'm going to finish them all
there so if you want to see that make
sure you go to to you know patreon air
Griffin patreon if you weren't doing
comedy what would world would your
career be you know what I still think
about finishing school and becoming
going into therapy I do I like doing
this so but I want to make sure I have
the proper tools and stuff
so
um yeah man so
anyways guys you know we did it again
riffing with Griffin you know felt like
again it seems like I was really on one
today on riffing with
Griffin so make sure you hit the
Subscribe button y'all make sure you hit
that subscribe button because I'm here
every Wednesday I go live you know
coming up I might miss a few just
because of you know like I say Daddy's
having a baby so you got to you got to
look into that that that might be uh
something that's going to be like uhoh
what happened to RI with Griffin I'm not
going away I'm just going to be you know
dealing with that okay so just keep that
in mind um make sure you hit me on
Twitch because this is where you can see
if you become a twitch subscriber you
can get the whole Monday live and then
you can you know I put those videos up
on patreon so make sure you go check me
out on patreon Eric Griffin on patreon
and I appreciate you guys always being
here
okay yeah you know what time it
is woo with that rap
recap uh uh
uh woo here on Griffin with
Griffin let's
recap paper straws are
whack you might get
sick real
quick don't take a li
[Music]
should be on
Kick reviewing the latest
[Music]
flick I love my old man RS you get slaps
you at home show me some
claps I hate when I use that beat
because it's never long
enough I got to remember that I got to
erase that one but shout out to my guy
shout out to my guy Chris U uh he sent
me I have so many great Beats from him
and I have great Beats from a lot of
people if you're a producer or DJ and
you want to send me a Beat Just make
sure it's not copywritten and then I'll
use it as my rap recap but anyways you
guys have been awesome thank you for
watching the show and I will see you
next
week